welcome back to las vegas now 20 billion
dollars that's the amount experts
predict we're gonna spend on father's
day wow but what are we buying and what
does dad really want we're getting all
of those answers from a social media
superstar do dad
he goes by dude dad and taylor thomas
has a mission to help other dads make
the most of family time
lowe's recently did a survey and found
that 70 percent of dads want to spend
more time with their kids
in a home improvement store which i
think just speaks to the fact that dads
like to build things we like to fix
things if that sounds familiar here are
ideas to step up his mr fix-it and diy
life the first is the blackstone flat
griddle grill make breakfast a new
experience bring the whole family
outside the backyard grill up some
breakfast um next gift is the cobalt 299
piece mechanic set this is basically
every hand tool that dad needs all in
one case the last idea is the ring
doorbell even if you're not home you
could be overseas somewhere somebody
comes your door rings your doorbell
you can see on video who's at your door
find these gift ideas and many more at
lowes.com